اريد ان اسالك عن الصور والفيديوهات التي
رايناها والتي قيل انها لاموال طائله لذهب
لمقتنيات في قصور الرئيس بن علي ما
حقيقتها انا استنجد دائما على الامور
الموضوعيه في هذا الشان هنالك امران
موضوعيه وزير الداخليه
الثوره اللي اسمه الراجحي
بعد خرج من الوزاره سرح رسميا بان المثل
الفلوس مثلا مستعملها همم مفتعله
واثنين تم التحقيق في قضيه الذهب ما الذهب
والبنك المركزي محافظ البنك المركزي انا
ذاك بينه وبالادله ما الذي امور مراقبه
اذن هناك افتعال في اطار سياسه شيطانه
والموجه الاعلاميه التي تمت حول شيطانه
بمختلف اشكال
مسلسلات وتمثيليات الى اخره
كلها فيها افتعال وافتعال والهدف منه
في فتره حكم الرئيس الاسبق بن علي في
قضايا عديده ومنها وهنا الى همم موضوع
الحمله التي همم تم خوضها على الحجاب
الاسلامي في عام 2006 زمن الرئيس الاسبق
زين العابدين بالعالي كيف يمكن ان نفهم
وان يقبل مجتمع مسلم ذلك
الحمله كانت حمله خطاب السياسي وفي
الاعلام
اثنين لان الحجاب فيه رمزيه بتاع عوده همم
عوده
الاسلاميين او الاسلاميين السياسيين الى
الشارع عن طريق هذه العلامه التي هي
الحجاب الذي لم يكن
لباسا ما هوذا في تونس
ولم يكن مستعمله
[موسيقى]